- [Interviewer] So stone,
- Yes sir,
- [Interviewer] Stone, where'd
you grow up originally?
- West Los Angeles man.
- [Interviewer] Did you grow up with both
of your parents?
- Uh, no, no, no, um
my father was in and out,
he had a couple of households.
I grew up on my mother's side.
Most of her brothers were
pimps, and hustlers and you know
that's what I grew up being attracted to.
You know, they were, you know, well,
what I thought they were
because I see them in
the alligator shoes, and
you know they used to dress
nicely what I thought.
But once I got older
I noticed they were heroin addicts.
So,
it kinda
threw me for a loop.
You know, I,
you know,
I had a couple of aunties.
I have one auntie died on
for taking (inaudible).
I had another auntie die off of, she shot
she shot heroine, she had an
overdose in the living room.
- [Interviewer] Oh wow.
- You know, I was probably
about nine years old.
Fucked me up,
I had to go get my mom, she was next door
and I had to get her
cause my auntie Connie was
foaming out her mouth man
you know, and from there
shit started changing for me.
I started looking at shit a lot different.
I grew up in the neighborhood, expected
you know what I'm saying?
As I say, my father wasn't there.
So most of the dudes on the streets that I
seen that was getting money
was what interested me.
That's what I said I wanted to be like.
- [Interviewer] Those
were your role models.
- These were my role models.
You know, dudes, Cadillacs
and so-called pimps,
and you know, back in it was sherm,
you know, they were selling sherm.
You know, I used to
stand on the street where
the sherm- I'm really not going
to give too many addresses
- [Interviewer] (laughs)
I don't want this.
- but sherm was like new
in my neighborhood right?
And we used to sit outside
and just see people
running down the street,
butt naked.
Seeing females, butt-naked
tripping, hugging poles
you know, we, little kids,
we ran around laughing, clowning.
And before you knew it,
we were selling that shit.
You know,
and this is what our neighborhood became.
Quite a few of us gravitated
down this way, to downtown.
When (inaudible) first came
out in my neighborhood,
I think I was probably
in about 17-18 years old.
You know, I quit going
to school because I was
getting money then.
You know, that seemed more, you know,
pops was already gone,
so it was more or less, you know,
mom, you can't tell me what to do.
I'm paying half the bills
in his place anyway.
So I started coming down here, man.
I did pretty good for a minute.
Went to jail quite a few times.
I think I'm, shit, in all actuality.
I think I got like four prison numbers.
I started using,
Let's say about 91-92,
had a spiral, lost everything.
- [Interviewer] What was your drug?
- Cocaine, crack cocaine.
- [Interviewer] Crack?
- Spiral, lost everything
man, out here on the streets.
You know, I went from here,
Hollywood was kinda going on then.
So we were in Hollywood, and
over there by MacArthur Park.
And it was like, the shit was so plentiful
and all the time, you
know what I'm saying?
It really wasn't.
We really didn't see
what it was doing to us.
You know, people that
knew you, they seen it,
but I'm out there every day.
You know, smoking handful of this shit,
still serving it, this is
how I'm keeping my high on.
So, you know, most of the drug dealers
they love me because I'm never going home.
I got half the business coming to me.
So, you know, it was, it was
pretty good for a minute.
And then I just,
I went to jail one time,
I think they gave me five on that one.
They gave me five in like '93,
I got out in '95 and said
I wasn't going to fuck with him no more.
So when I got out,
I kind of still went back and forth
but I hooked up with one of
my homies that was down here
that was really getting money.
And he was like, man, such and such,
owes me man.
You know what I'm saying?
You go get this for me.
I give you this.
And you know, I went over there
took a stick over there,
told him you know,
"You owe my home boy"
hit him a couple of times, you know,
slapped the female that was in the tent.
Towards the house, and I'm
beating her at the end.
- [Interviewer] And so a
new career was born for you?
- [Stone] A new career was born
and I never want to sell
dope again in my life.
For that little episode right there,
I think my boy gave me about $150.
And I think that took
me about three minutes.
I was out of there in like three minutes,
cashed out.
He told somebody else
"Stone will do that shit,
Stone will do it".
So from that point on man,
every damn day everybody down there,
if somebody was owed something, you know
I'm finna go through there tripping
and they gonna get paid.
- [Interviewer] How often
when you walk into somebody's
face and, they claim
they don't have the money
do they actually have the money?
- [Stone] Nine times out of 10,
If it's somebody that's just smoked out,
no they don't.
But the ones who are trying
to serve they have it,
they have it, they have it.
I need to go up bitches ass
to get their money in everyday, man.
You know what I'm saying?
Cause that shit, you wouldn't believe it
but it's plentiful down here man.
- [Interviewer] What's what's
the most violent you've ever
had to get to get money out of somebody?
- [Stone] With this bat man,
I had to hit this dude and
he actually had the money.
I know I broke the arm when I hit it.
- [Interviewer] What kind
of, what kind of bat?
- It's a Louisville Slugger,
its smaller than the mini ones
that you get at Dodger's Stadium.
- [Interviewer] Oh, the smaller ones.
- [Stone] The smaller ones,
wrapped it up with electrical tape man,
- [Interviewer] much faster.
- [Stone] Much faster and
it's easy to,
So anyway, I had to hit him in the arm.
I know I broke the arm when
I hit it cause it fell.
Even then, he still
didn't want to give it.
Once I cracked him in the head one time
he told me it was over there
and he had every dime of it.
So, you know, I mean it's people
sometimes people don't
understand nothing but violence.
The cold part about it, you know?
And, and if they figured that they can get
away or see somebody
else get away with it,
ain't nobody gonna pay
you your money, man.
Figure you're a punk.
Not going to tell you shit,
but if you send somebody
over there to get it
or they send somebody
they know they come in and get the money
they going to pay me.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, and
once you've done that once
- once you've done that once,
now they know when I'm coming,
they finna pay.
Cause I'm not playing.
- [Interviewer] Makes your life easy.
- It makes it real easy.
You know, I didn't have the, you know
(inaudible)
shoot in the air a couple of times.
And once that actually occurred,
once things like that become a nature.
As soon as they see me come,
"Hey man, look here, man.
I got this money, man,
take this right here."
Cause they know that it's we not playing.
So I mean,
I been stopped a few times.
They just tried to get me
all kinds of bullshit charges
but they really have nothing on me.
So, but as I say, man,
I stopped selling dope.
Ooh, it's been like 10 years, man.
I don't want have nothing
to do with that shit.
It don't even make no sense to me no more.
- [Interviewer] Do you use drugs at all?
- I use a little bit of crystal now.
I don't know what I'm up in out here
but you know what I'm saying?
- [Interviewer] But you're
not a hardcore addict?
- I buy my, I went through that,
I went through that with that crack
and I don't want to sell all day
I want to see nothing
like that no more bro.
You know? And you know, I got a daughter,
my daughter's 23 and I
got a grandson right now.
So, you know, and for the most part, man
I'm out here really just,
I do that a little bit,
but I'm out here more
helping people than hurting people today.
I really, I'm really trying
to see people get the fuck up outta here.
You know, I got a couple of people
that have a sober livings and stuff.
So if you willing, you
know, I'll do what I can.
- [Interviewer] What do you think
keeps people down here? I
mean, it seems like their,
their mindset is that they belong here.
This is there, this is
what they're worthy of.
- Yeah, it's, it's actually a lot
of people just addicted to drama.
I mean, drugs has a
small bit to do with it
but I think me personally,
see I kind of went to school for this
but me personally, man,
I think that it has a lot to
do with how you was raised,
whatever went on in your life.
People don't want to deal
with problems that they have,
you know, because once you get to the core
of what got you doing this,
then you try to find a solution.
You can't just,
drugs is the problem.
Drugs is the problem.
No, you, the problem,
you got to figure what the
fuck is going on with you.
Once you get to that,
then you could probably open it up and
start getting rid of some of that shit.
For the most part, man, like I say,
a lot of people went through
a lot of traumatic shit
in their life, you know?
Cause I talk to pretty much everybody.
And some of the shit
that they been through,
until they deal with that,
until they actually see it themselves.
Once you get it on paper
and see it yourself
and then see what you
want to do to change it.
For one time I thought
those 12 steps was bullshit.
But then I started really looking at it,
that fourth and fifth step,
a lot shit of going on with that
because you get to write down and see
what's going on with you.
And then you go back and you apologize
to the people you hurt.
Which actually frees up that spirit.
Once that spirit is free, man
you kind of get a chance
to deal with a new you.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- [Stone] Because if you can honestly stay
trapped in that old shit,
that's what you're going to do.
I think it was said to me,
if you always do what you always did.
You're going to always
get what you always got.
- [Interviewer] All right, Stone,
thank you so much for talking to me.
- Not a problem man, not a problem.
- [Interviewer] Good luck with everything.